voilà alors et je voudrais dire aussi un
truc j'ai vu beaucoup beaucoup de tweets
je vous lis et vous le savez on est unis
à minuit et demi ça j'ai vu beaucoup de
tweets concernant l'émission voilà sur
tmc quotidien ou plein de gens sont
plein hier qui ont dit oui ils ont prévu
de faire le discours de macron de parier
discours de mâcon ils ont parlé de la
cathédrale notre dame justement à la fin
je ne suis pas la moitié moi je dis
toujours la vérité je suis là pour voilà
on défende les mecs quand il ya une
connerie qui dit sachez qu'ils sont pas
tous ne sont pas en direct quotidien
donc ils ont essayé de faire le maximum
possible parce qu'ils sont ils sont ils
sont pas en direct crois qu'il ya 20
minutes d'écart
voilà on dirait qu'ils sont qu'en direct
quotidien donc ils ont fait le maximum
pour essayer de couvrir l'événement mais
malheureusement ils étaient eux sur le
discours de macron il avait prévu tout
une émission sur le discours de macron
il savait même savais pas que le
discours de macron été annulé parce que
l'émission n'est pas en direct
voilà j'ai vu beaucoup de gens leur
tomber dessus voilà vous allez dire non
mais c'est pas ni des ennemis ni des
amis mais au moins qu'on y a voilà des
gens qui moi j'aime pas quand on voit là
quand on s'acharne sur des mecs et qu'à
une erreur voilà c'est juste qu'il
n'était pas en direct et qu' ils n'ont
pas pu voilà courir le truc et qu'ils
ont essayé de le faire à la fin
en envoyant un envoyé spécial et voilà
ils ont essayé de faire le max mais
c'est pas voilà c'est pas de leur faute
voilà c'est voilà et je vous dis la
vérité
ils sont obligés de ne pas être en
direct puisque dans toutes les chaînes
maintenant ils demandent souvent de ne
pas être en direct même danse avec les
stars the voice est pas en direct tout à
fait parce que s'il ya un événement ou
un truc en dépassant plateau et nous
peuvent maîtriser l'antenne fait comment
vous l'avez jamais de moi j'étais
toujours au fusil d'alarmé mois ci un
fort mal dirigés sur noir quoi oui mais
voilà ils sont obligés oui mais où il va
l'attendre irak six obligé vous dire il
ya que moi qui refuse et je peux vous
dire je prends un risque mais sachez que
je n'ai pas le droit de le faire
normalement voilà je vous dis mais eux
sont dans leur bon droit
et moi je suis je suis pas dans le nom
mon droit puisque quotidien que soit
quotidien que ce soit les émissions
grand divertissement ils doivent laisser
dans ce qu'il appelle un timing il ya un
temps on peut nettoyer s'il se passe
quelque chose quand des responsables de
nantes exactement la crise et nous on
est les seuls à la haye traduire à dire
voilà iront qu'on ne le fait pas mais on
sait pas bien